Community Pride on Las Vegas now is
sponsored by Findlay automotive group
Southwest Medical part of Optum care
Silver State Schools Credit Union and NV
Energy
Finley Automotive the sponsors of this
segment have partnered with the local
organization to keep women in our
community unshakable here to explain is
Jeff Giles of Findlay automotive and
Debbie Isaac's founder of unshakable
welcome thank you so much yet again
another partnership to help our
community from Findlay automotive so
Jeff explained what inspired you guys to
support this group yeah so we found out
about them that was what inspired us
it's all about word of mouth right so we
we heard about them and their mission of
empowering women just aligns so much
with what we want to do we want to
empower every employee we want to you
know everybody that works in an
organization want them to feel empowered
to like take charge and and make great
decisions to to benefit the whole team
and um so really it was just just just
finding out about what they do and then
making some connections and um you know
the amazing thing is with with uh
charities in this town we you know we
work with so many different ones and
every once in a while you find out
there's another one that's amazing you
really you'll never run out yeah of
people to help here a testament to the
community which is great so Debbie let's
take it to you now um what what made you
start this organization unshakable you
know I tell people that I was working as
a in video production and a bit
selfishly I was going to do a
documentary on a program at the
specialty courts called women in need of
change
and I went in wanting to tell their
story and came out knowing I needed to
change it so we started I started
unshakable and we are focused on helping
women recovering from trauma so
homelessness addiction uh sexual
violence victims human trafficking
return to the workforce and much more
than a check the box here's your job
mentality much more career focused a
little bit deeper dive okay so what is
that deeper dive what kind of programs
are you offering how are you getting
these women recovered you know we we
have a program called Empower to employ
it's three phases phase one we built a
two-day Women's Conference it's about 16
hours of training we teach business
acculturation so business Communications
you know how to interview yeah we do
classes on building self-esteem and then
we teach life skills for adults so we
won't teach you how to diaper your kid
but we will prepare you for the work for
us phase two is our our one-on-one
career coaching which we commit to each
client for up to two years
and that we do a deep dive you know
we're overcoming whatever barriers they
have to employment both physical and
emotional so Child Care Transportation
you know whatever they need whatever
needs are to us that we will take care
of that work with them on that and then
the last part and one of the exciting
things with Finley is we partner with
businesses some Fortune 200 some local
companies Findlay just became one of our
hiring Partners wonderful where they
agree to interview our clients not
guaranteed a job but certainly interview
understand their experience real life
experiences and so they're our newest
Partners so I you'll be seeing some of
our clients you know customer service in
Finland and Finley so it's great good
good well thank you for supporting such
an important organization is there
website that people can sure uh you know
unshakable.com org you could get
information donations
volunteers were always looking for
people in the community to help out all
right thank you so much Jeff and Debbie
Mercedes I'll send it to you